next month the nation's two largest
theater chains will reopen for the first
time since the pandemic struck while
moviegoers couldn't see new releases
during these last few months in theaters
two young film buffs saw something else
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to get
into the Hollywood history books
Jamie Wax reports Joss you're gonna need
a bigger coach Independence Day
earth Avengers endgame Assemble
[Music]
and unsubscribe oh my god
one of these movies have in common they
each held the number one spot at the
u.s. box office during the coveted
summer season wait haven't heard of
unsubscribe a 29 minute horror film shot
on zoom' over four days with virtually
no budget and a non-existent marketing
campaign well sit back have some popcorn
if you got it and enjoy a tale of
creativity ingenuity and pandemic erase
your account I will you the moment it
pops into my head like I noticed that
box office numbers were so low and I've
been trying to make content I was like
if I can make the number one box office
movie in America that's a huge idea the
story begins with actor and youtuber
Eric taboc and writer director Christian
Nilsson started a YouTube channel and
just film little videos at home and do
they have Deal or No Deal let's go back
to the beginning of this YouTube met at
BuzzFeed in 2018 didn't click at first
but then found a shared love of movies
right well I clicked but he didn't click
immediately started messaging him
wanting to make videos with him
fast forward to 2020 after an Emmy win
for Nilsson and YouTube success for
taboc when both had big projects on the
horizon including a fully funded first
feature for Nilsson titled Westhampton
after his Long Island home town it was a
project that I had been working on for
about five years and Kovac 19 came along
and I think investors got scared I was
just starting to work with a company
that was funding a show and I wanted to
do this big project on YouTube and then
they I think lost investors as well
dropped my show right away so then I
called Christian I started updating him
on like videos idea as I was working on
but you put this entire idea out there
yeah a conversation that so that's where
it saw at first I didn't know exactly
how to do it I was like all I know is we
need to make a small amount of money to
be able to be named number one box
office movie in America and so we
thought if we can get a theater
next to nothing and spend among
ourselves that money essentially is
gonna funnel out of our right pocket and
just go back to our left pocket and so
so this is something that was never
really possible prior to this moment and
I think that we just realized it at the
right time for the plan to work things
had to come together in an insanely
quick way so May 7th he calls me and we
realize feeders and they're open up in 3
or 4 weeks you were racing against the
clock it's been getting a lot of
attention how it was written in one day
and shot in four days a one but we had
to be fast because we had to get this
thing out as quick as we could and the
entire process was done I want to put
you you assembled a very impressive cast
and a lot of major youtubers with a lot
of followers and also Charlie tahan of
Ozark who's a very hot property right
now
I was just persistent and annoying
I sent like 50 voice memo is that people
being like do you want to be a part of
the number one box office movie in
America let's do it and with a theater
in West Hampton rented filming via zoom
complete and some two hundred fifty
seven hours of post-production finished
just under the wire Nielsen and taboc
gave the film a proper premiere cycling
their money through the box-office over
five showings for a total gross of
twenty five thousand four hundred eighty
eight dollars I love the fact the movie
is on the marquee sold out and that you
guys put on tuxes they came in and made
it a real premiere I mean it was a
special event you have to wear a tuxedo
and within days of its brief theatrical
run unsubscribed had cemented its place
in movie history how did it feel when
you saw your movie at the top of those
official lists it was crazy
it felt like a like I love sorry I had
called you and I was just like we did it
that entire morning we were waiting for
those websites to report it was really
stressful it was just a moment of relief
because my fiancee right afterward said
one movie in America thought of that we
just need this short film and then that
is the number one film in America how
soon after all this got reported did the
press come calling not right away I
think there were like a couple days
where we were like oh my god nobody
cares like this this was so stupid
we felt like idiots and then all hell
broke loose and then and then it just
blew up and it's just been this
incredible ride ever since the next
morning we woke up to requests from
outlets across the country which we were
hoping for initially but we didn't
expect the interest globally if you
google our names articles from France
Spain Hungary Russia Africa this story
went everywhere I was I was seeing
languages I mean recognized even though
they've now garnered international
attention Nilsson and taboc definitely
don't see this as the end of their story
the immediate goal is to a feature film
that I've been writing and film that
outside have that go into a real theater
with a real audience and really get
placed on the box office charts no more
empty theatres for you guys no more
empty beers for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie whacks West Hampton New
York that story's awesome and you've got
like a million people now Michelle sing
like why didn't I think of that why
didn't I do that right can you believe
it I just can't